[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is new this is the sharp aquos crystal
the most interesting phone in the world
right now no but seriously this is one
of the most intriguing phones i've seen
in a long time and for one huge reason
or i guess one tiny reason
that bezel all the way around this phone
except for the bottom you have a minimal
bezel that basically melts over the side
so really looks like there's no bezel at
all so on the fourth side on the bottom
it has this huge chin and i call this
the moto 360 approach basically this
design is the reason we're looking at
this phone at all it's the reason it's
caught so many eyes a lot of people are
now interested in it this might be a
stretch but it kind of reminds me of the
zune hd from way back in the day anyone
no uh well it has the prominent chin on
the bottom and the smaller side bezels
that remind me of that but looking at
other phones on the market there really
isn't anything else like this so i
wanted to show it to you guys get eyes
on this thing share it around because i
like when manufacturers take risks like
this so props to sharp for thinking
outside the box so we're looking at a 5
inch 720p edge to edge display and at
all those edges is the piece of glass on
the front of the phone that chamfers
straight down to the metal sides in a
way that's pretty smooth and seamless
giving it a pretty dope look
obviously the chin isn't the prettiest
thing in the world but you gotta put the
display driver somewhere and overall it
doesn't really look terrible as a whole
package also on the bottom you also have
your front-facing selfie camera which
actually asks you to hold the phone
upside down to take selfies that aren't
at a weird angle and the white led
notification light is down in the bottom
as well now one of the sacrifices they
made for that bezel-less display is not
having an earpiece on the top and
although it is a bit of a sacrifice
they've also kind of made it into a
feature instead of having an earpiece
they still have a back facing speaker
but instead of having an earpiece on the
top for calls the entire glass front
panel here vibrates so when you make a
call and you put your ear up to anywhere
on the display you'll hear whoever
you're calling it's a similar technology
to what you have in that bone conduction
speaker in google glass that vibrates
against your temple anywhere you put
this phone up against your head you can
hear it because it's vibrating the whole
screen and it's actually decent quality
too so they kind of turned a sacrifice
into a bit of a feature so using this
display holding it and getting used to
it was pretty quick to get used to and
soon you start to see every other
phone's big bezels
start to look even bigger but you get a
few nice aesthetic advantages with this
edge to edge screen so for one the
camera's viewfinder looks really cool
it's a five inch full screen viewfinder
and while it's not even a good camera at
all
you get a pretty good idea of what it's
like to really take advantage edge to
edge of a full screen from corner to
corner so i just thought that looked
pretty neat the camera is definitely one
of the better looking apps that you can
open on this phone another thing was
videos and gaming so videos of course
play back full screen and they create
this immersive experience even though
it's a five inch display it's not the
biggest in the world but you can imagine
being able to focus really well now on
the media more instead of the device
you're watching it on and of course
gaming so games full screen look really
great too
but it's not all pros obviously when the
display goes edge to edge like this you
do have a couple of cons couple
sacrifices you still need to hold it
somewhere and yeah the device is pretty
thick on the side so you can hold it on
the sides but even so i found myself
kind of obstructing the view of the
screen by accident sometimes just by
holding it kind of wrong and also
durability is going to suffer it's
basically impossible to make a case for
this phone that doesn't cover up part of
the screen if you think about it so
you're going to be carrying it naked and
if you drop it on any of the sides other
than the bottom you're basically making
impact with the screen since there's no
bezel to shield it so yeah you're gonna
have to be extra careful handling this
guy to not drop it and to not
accidentally press stuff
and like i said it's actually a five
inch display but it feels way way
smaller than any other 5-inch phone i've
ever held in fact the body of it is
smaller than the iphone 6 body and the
iphone 6 is a smaller 4.7 inch display
so i mean this aquos crystal is
seriously compacted around its five-inch
display i didn't even realize it was a
five-inch display until i looked it up i
would have thought it's more like 4.5
and it is a 720p display so it comes in
at just under 300 pixels per inch and
it's not exactly super sharp or retina
display or anything
uh but this isn't a high-end phone this
is a low to mid-range prepaid phone that
costs 150 bucks on amazon i'll leave a
link right below that like button if you
want to check it out
you can get this phone prepaid with
boost or sprint but yeah basically it's
150 bucks so really in terms of unique
features once you get past the display
in the design
basically ends there
it's running a lower end qualcomm chip
and has what a gig and a half of ram
eight gigabytes of onboard storage and
it's running a very near stock build of
android 4.4 with a few features that
sharp has built in so
one is it has harman kardon audio which
is supposedly going to add clarity to
your audio but i'd put that in the same
category as beats audio i wouldn't
really worry about that and it also has
some fancy full screen animations that
can turn on when your phone is charging
or when your alarm clock is going off
basically this is sharp adding some
features in the settings saying hey look
at me look how freaking cool this looks
to not have a bezel please notice how
good this looks uh and honestly it does
look pretty cool but yeah performance
it's okay not spectacular it does
stutter once in a while uh especially
when web browsing or gaming but nothing
too extreme
battery life was a bit better than i
expected actually thanks to the 720p
display so thumbs up there
and really that's the whole deal with
this device it's not a flagship like i
said cortex a7 chip eight gigs of
storage it has a micro sd card slot in
the back but you can't remove or swap
the battery
this whole phone is more of trying new
things with a new design that no one has
ever really pushed before and i am so
down for more stuff like this i like
when companies push the boundaries of
design and what phones should look like
or feel like in the hand and even if
this phone won't make a lot of money for
sharp which it probably won't i'm glad
they took that risk i'm glad they're
taking risks and that's why i'm sharing
this i want people to see this i want
new eyeballs on this stuff and hopefully
other manufacturers try some more
outlandish or more interesting stuff too
this particular one isn't the phone for
me but i am glad it exists